welcome back to CBS mornings we are
sharing a big update on the story that
we've been following here for years
actually Aaron's been following it for
years we appreciate that Aaron about a
prison inmate in Missouri who shows the
power of transformation and Second
Chances his name is Bobby Bostic he was
serving a 241 year sentence you're that
right
241 years for a series of robberies he
committed when he was just 16. Bostic is
now 43 he changed his life in prison how
he went to school he read and wrote
books even though he had no hope of
getting out but that all changed thanks
to a very unlikely Ally 48 Hours
correspondent Aaron Moriarty as we said
she's been covering Boston's case for a
very long time this is a very exciting
update good morning good to see you but
we've all been following it along
following you following it it's true
well what Bostick did in prison was
extraordinary he got an education he
wrote 15 books so we have had to be
there last week when Bobby bossick was
released after more than 27 years thanks
to the judge who first put him behind
bars
43 year old Bobby bossick was making
more than a fashion statement when he
walked away from a Missouri prison last
week in a brand new suit the new me the
suits represent new me and it's a
business suit and often to go on with
the new business of life so that's what
the superbers think boss six first hug
Evelyn Baker God I'm so happy happy the
now retired judge who sent Bostic to
prison but spent the last four years
fighting to get him out you were
emotional when he walked out towards you
yep
he made me cry all right wasn't trying
to this day one seemed inconceivable
bossick was incarcerated in 1995 at age
16 after he and a friend committed a
series of armed robberies in St Louis
one victim was grazed by a bullet did
you intend to hurt him to kill him no I
attend to her to kill him I'd have kept
shooting convince Bostic was a lost
cause Judge Baker showed no mercy after
he was convicted on 17 counts the judge
ordered his sentences to run
consecutively for a total of 241 years
we visited basican prison again two
weeks before his release were you angry
with her no it motivated me to say one
day if I ever do get out I will see her
and she would realize the mistakes she
made and when she see the person I
became that didn't seem very likely
Bostic wouldn't be eligible for parole
until he was 112 years old many people
would have just given up but basic found
Drive even when he had nowhere to go
once you make so many mistakes you get
tired and you want to do something
different so I started reading that's
how I found myself in books and that's
the most piece I ever get in the world
it's a natural high basically boss a
contained an associate's degree and is
working now on his bachelor's in
business he wrote poetry and prose 15
books in all including a biography of
his mother His stunning turnaround
convinced Judge Baker she made a mistake
241 years is insanity when I think back
on it and I'll say right now it's
insanity he was a kid he was a little
boy but you're the one who sentenced him
judge yes as he evolved I have evolved I
mean is it fair to say that the case of
Bobby vasik has haunted you
that would be a very true statement
Judge Baker began advocating for Bostic
in the summer of 2021 the Missouri
legislature passed the Bobby bossick Law
which allowed him and other inmates
incarcerated his juveniles to apply for
parole how unusual is that for the trial
judge who sentenced an inmate to then
appear at the parole hearing asking for
his release I don't know if it ever
happened before
but it was something I wanted to do why
because it was time for Bobby to come
home and be with his family
he wasn't a kid I sent and late last
year the parole board gave basic a date
when he could finally go home and then
when I see my name on the paper this
morning and said released Bobby bossy
released I'm like it's official
so you do have a very strange unique
Bond
yes you put him in prison and you helped
him get out
the Barbie Bostic I put in prison is not
the Bobby Bostic who got out
Bobby
did what many people can't do
he created himself
he took The Good The Bad and The Ugly
and he turned into something that's
quite beautiful
you feel good about today I'm ecstatic
this is better than Christmas Easter
Fourth of July Thanksgiving rolling in
one
my God his family thought so too
there'll be some people who won't think
you and other men who've been convicted
as juveniles deserve a second chance
what do you say to them oh well some
people
um they got a right to feel that way
basically right it's up to us the
juveniles will get out and get the
second chance to do something different
to prove to those people like I'm just
like you
um
in case you're wondering none of basic's
victims objected to his release and one
even wrote a letter supporting him
nationally more and more inmates
arrested as juveniles are getting Second
Chances in Missouri none of those
released in this past year have
reoffended nor have any returned to
prison I should point out and you
probably realize this he has a lot to be
thankful for and you could probably
guess where he and his family are
spending Thanksgiving with the judge yes
there was a lady hugging him in the car
that's his sister Marquis and that's
who's he's living with right now and she
owns a cleaning company and he's going
to work there I can still get to come in
with the judge I didn't see that yeah I
think it's going to be hard for him he
has not made any decisions for himself
or yeah the last 27 years harder than
what I think he realized I'm glad the
judges evolved Aaron but I do wonder
what took so long well I don't think she
realized how much he had changed I was
very impressed to learn how much lawyers
who work for the ACLU ACLU in Missouri
have worked on this case and they
reached out to her um and they're the
ones who really lobbied for this great
story appreciate you that was awesome
thank you